I can do anything with many people and ogres, but the
devil is the only one I'm not allowed to love because of the Axis religion's precepts.
Unfortunately,
what can a priest who is just a human being do to bury you?
Yes, I can.
[Music] You
say something interesting. A
great photo.
This person who serves Lord Walbak [
Music]
Sorry I'm late, demon child. My name is
Zesta, and I'm an Ark Priest who serves as the chief executive of the Axis Church.  Similarly, I am the
beauty of Akan.It
seems like it was because of the
devil that
Zesta-sama was subjected to such a thing.
What on earth are you talking about? I am in this town  I
came here, but I kept looking for Mr. Wolbach.
[Music]
[Music] I
ran away. I'll make you
regret being born. I
understand.
[Music]
[Applause]
Don't ask me what happened.  please